[Music]
thank you
it's not just a myth what do you think
that all these cultures all these people
have stories about a flood
we now have more evidence than ever
from ancient Advanced civilizations like
the yonaguni monument
evolutionists call this
over 4 000 years ago there was a flood
we now have more evidence than ever that
proves that there was a flood more than
four thousand years ago we have
archeology that proves it and we have
basically all the stories from all
cultures across the whole globe that
proves it you can also take some time
just to look at some of the recent
discoveries from ancient Advanced
civilizations like the yonaguni monument
[Music]
the 70 rock paintings found along the
Jinja river in China
tiwanaku in South America
Lake Titicaca
the Puma punka ruins
[Music]
the chatata wall in Cleveland
the Indus building settlements of
present-day India and Pakistan
the ancient city of Uruk and the story
of Gilgamesh
the ancient civilization found in a
Black Sea just 12 miles off the coast of
Turkey
[Music]
found by Dr Robert D Ballard the same
man who found the Titanic
and then of course there's called
Blackie Tepe in Turkey
almost all of these sites are older than
4500 BC
and most of them are built in such a way
that for us as humans even today it is
impossible to replicate it so most of
them must have been built by the
Nephilim in the pre-flood world that we
know or some people know as the
anti-diluvian period the world was
totally different there was a lot less
water than we have now and more land
most of the continents were connected
known as Pangea
so that is why a lot of the evidence of
these ancient civilizations was
discovered underwater just like the one
that they found in the Black Sea it used
to be above water when the flood came it
didn't just rain from above water burst
through the Earth's crust Genesis 7
verse 10 says and after seven days the
Waters of the flood Came Upon the Earth
in the 6th hundredth year of Noah's life
in the second month on the 17th day of
the month on that day all The Fountains
of the great deep burst forth and the
windows of the heavens were opened and
rain fell upon the Earth 40 days and 40
nights
so water from inside the Earth's crust
came forth just like fountains and also
water from above it is rained we still
have in a lot of areas across the globe
those cracks those areas where The
Fountains of the deep burst through they
are called fault lines scars of the
cracks and some are still moving like a
subduction plate sliding underneath
another one now you might have also
realized while I was reading this
passage that Noah was 600 years old yeah
a lot of the people before the flood
they got old some over 900 years but
I'll cover that in the next video so the
World Before the Flood was different
people lived longer after the flood it
was different we have a lot more water
now
there was definitely a flood and we
don't just read that from the Bible but
from other civilizations not just two or
three but almost from all of them for
example the Sumerians have a flood story
where the gods set out to destroy
mankind the sea god enki informs
ziasutra the ruler of shurupak secretly
about it to build a large boat
the flood came and as it ends ziasutra
honors the gods through sacrifice
the Epic of Gilgamesh was recorded on 12
stone tablets it says the supreme god is
determined to destroy Humanity as it has
grown to noisy but the god Ayah told
specific information to build a ship
called preserver of life
he did it and he survived the flood he
built it and brought all his relatives
and all species of creatures on the ship
as well
the Aztecs believed that Lacon warned
the man named note and his wife Nina of
a coming flood
not the Nina hollowed out a cypress tree
and sitla kahun sealed him inside
selling them that they may only eat one
ear of maize each
the Greeks believed Zeus was displeased
with the human population he told
ducalian the son of Prometheus to build
an ark for himself and his wife perha
after nine days of flooding the world
was destroyed and the Ark rested on top
of Mount Parnassus
there are many stories the Chinese for
example they do not just have one story
but many here's one of them during the
reign of Emperor Yao the yellow river
valleys flooded entirely across the land
yao-san un the great used the enchanted
staff which would one day belong to
Wukong to dig channels and trenches that
lowered the waters another Chinese story
is about fuhai his wife three sons and
three daughters just like Noah and his
family they escaped a great flood and
were the only people alive on Earth
after the great flood they repopulated
the world
in Hindu Stories the god Vishnu appeared
to the first man Manu in the form of a
fish and told him that the world will be
destroyed by a great flood so he built a
big boat for himself and his family with
seeds and animals to replenish the Earth
again
in Buddhism the flood story is called
samuda vanilla yataka a long story about
1 000 families of dishonest Carpenters
ruled by a wise leader and foolish
leader now the story is too long to tell
in detail but in the end the wise men
built a ship and survived the flood on
the island with his followers while the
foolish leader and his followers died
because they fell for the trick of a
spirit and did not build a ship there's
a lot of flood stories we have stories
from from Persia Syria Italy Lithuania
Russia from the cree of Canada from the
Cherokee of America Papago from Mexico
Peru Hawaii and delicious goes on
now let's just stop here
there was a flood it's not just a myth
what do you think that all these
cultures all these people have stories
about a flood is because it really
happened some of the stories changed
over time and that is what will happen
if you continue to tell a story but
these civilizations lived far away from
each other thousands of miles and at
different time periods and yet they tell
the same story
we're going to deny these stories
especially when we have so much
geological evidence as well it is our
human story history that's where we come
from Noah's descendants stayed together
for around 100 years until God confused
their languages at Babel if you recall
from my previous video now as these
people moved and spread across the world
their descendants formed Nations each of
their own languages
so they would have shared these stories
in their languages until it became
embedded in their culture
there are some people who don't want you
to believe
that there was a flood and advanced
ancient civilizations Before the Flood
because they don't want you to believe
that the Bible is true and evolution is
wrong
the fact that advanced civilizations
existed more than 4 500 years ago it
goes directly against their whole Theory
their ideology so they try to ridicule
anyone who goes against them even
non-christians like Graham Hancock who
created the series ancient apocalypse
you can watch it now on Netflix people
like Graham have found so much evidence
of pre-flood civilizations
that you cannot deny it but you will
rarely see it on TV or news controlled
by the people who want you to believe in
evolution
so what other evidence do we have If
there really was a flood
well it's all over if you just open your
eyes and just look like Ken Ham says
it's from the seabeds to the
mountaintops you can see it everywhere
you drive if you drive in your car or
when you fly a plane by just looking at
the physical features of the Earth
everywhere you go that shows us that
there was a huge flood that covered the
Earth so if there was a flood you would
expect many dead things right fossils of
plants animals and humans that died
quickly right
well that is exactly what we found
everywhere you look there are layers of
sand soil and material laid down by
water in these sedimentary layers we
found billions of dead things fossils
from animals and plants that were buried
very quickly and not over decades or
millions of years
so is there any evidence of these
fossils that shows us that they died
very quickly apart from just in the
layers that they were buried in the
sedimentary layers
yes like this fish we found eating
another fish not having enough time to
swallow it and the tons of mudslides and
sediments buried it instantly they also
found an itchy sore basically giving
birth to a baby and suddenly they were
covered in mud buried and became fossils
how long does it take certain animals to
give birth
not millions of years
there are also fossils that we found
that are so perfectly preserved that it
would be impossible to be that perfectly
preserved if it died over a long period
of time look at this wasp fossil the
perfect Wings you can look at Sea lilies
jellyfish and and many other fossils
if fossils came from millions of years
and if they evolved over those millions
of years we should have found evidence
of the transition fossils where they
transitioned from one type of creature
to another I mean the whole earth should
be full of them
we don't find any evolutionists call
this
missing links there's no evidence of
this anywhere all the creatures of the
fossil records are fully formed and
fully functioning without any hint of
ancient ancestors that looked
differently
now these group of people who want to
mislead you to doubt God's word
they've been doing it Through the Ages
and they're using Evolution Darwin's
theory to try to mislead you to believe
in a lie and to doubt God
that says that he created the world
here's something interesting Charles
Darwin himself said this in 1859 why
then is not every geological formation
and every stratum full of such
intermediate links geology assuredly
does not reveal such finely graduated
organic chain
meaning animals evolved over time
there's no evidence of it and this
perhaps is the most obvious and serious
objection which can be urged against the
theory do they tell you these kind of
things in your textbooks kids in school
did you get it when you grew up in
school of course not they won't tell you
these things Darwin thought that they
would find these missing links probably
sometime it's been over 200 years we've
found none and by the way for me it's
very interesting that Darwin's wife Emma
was a devout Christian
you know textbooks used to say in the
beginning God created
a few decades ago everything changed and
even the first sentence you'll find in
many books is
billions of years ago or millions of
years ago and they tried to explain
everything with the passage of time
but animals evolved for example they say
this fish called kulakans has been
extinct for 66 billion years
they found this fossil of it do you know
how long one million years really is
I mean that's just
so long so they say this fish has been
extinct for 66 billion years where they
even come up with these numbers
it's interesting when you compare the
books of a few decades years ago and you
look at them now with the new books you
see that
these years are not the same they keep
on changing well the fact is
this fish species was not extinct they
first founded in 1938 off the coast of
Madagascar and South Africa where I come
from
now if evolution is true I mean 66
billion years is a long
time period so that fish should have
looked different by now if evolution is
true
the fish is exactly the same
the fact is that these fossils came from
the time period of the flood not 66
billion years ago all the fossils we
found of animals and plants are still
the same as they are today crabs are
still crabs beetles are still beetles
and the list goes on
now what is interesting is if the flood
is true you know there would have been a
few animals that were together you know
with the flood
is that what we found yes we found
graveyards of animals
meaning they died at the same time there
are fossil graveyards of Clans corals
brachiopods crinoids and trolleybytes
now I mentioned that we have a lot of
seashells in on dry land you know miles
away from the ocean which is strange
number one but we also find number two
chalk beds on dry land and not just here
and there but it's just all over the
globe that's trillions of microscopic
shells
from the English Channel Coast across
Europe and into Israel they're also
found in the midwest USA and in South
Western Australia
where did it come from
well there was a flood
so there used to be water and it carried
the seashells
now guess what we found in these jog
beds
Grinders fish fossils pliosaurs turtle
fossils and other Dino and bird fossils
so not only do we find the evidence of a
lot of animals that died quickly on dry
land but also sea life that died in dry
land
how is this possible
well there was a flood
the world was covered with water for
example we have these fossil graveyards
like the Agate Fossil Beds of the
National Monument of Nebraska
there's also evidence of ocean life
embedded in the Limestone on Mount
Everest's Summit
fossils of crinoids ancient underwater
animals with tentacles and cone-shaped
shells
how did sea life
get all the way to the top of Mount
Everest
laughs
because there was a flood the Earth was
covered with water the flood also caused
the coal and the oil that we have today
Imagine This
with the water just raising every tide
it gets higher higher higher right and
there's waves coming in every wave just
knocks down trees in life and then you
get all these layers from the sea up
until the mountaintops and that's how we
get these layers of oil and coal
explained it pretty well
I have a theory about the oil here's my
theory okay I believe about 6 000 years
ago God created everything 4 400 years
ago there was a flood okay in that flood
lots of Critters and people drowned
they got buried by the gravel and the
rocks and the mud and the sand and it
got pretty heavy after a while and it
squished them into oil
so the oil is down there today from the
people and animals that drowned in that
flood
you know in most places where you find
oil the pressure is unbelievable have
you ever seen how somebody finds oil it
comes squirting out of the Earth with
immense power some places found the
pleasure to be twenty thousand pounds
per square inch PSI there's no way that
the Earth can hold these pockets of oil
with that immense pressure for billions
of years
no they can't even hold it for over 10
000 years
and the flood that happened around 4 500
years ago so it makes sense oil is made
from squishing organisms together and
there is still pressure because this
happened 4 500 years ago at the time of
the flood
Now evolutionists teach kids and well
they probably did when you were in
school unless you were a bad student and
you were too lazy and you couldn't care
less but you probably saw it on TV
anyway
the point is this they teach that when
you look at the Earth and you see those
different layers right those layers
represents different ages the geological
column they call it is their time scale
even the Jurassic age is also in there
they say all animals evolved over time
and different animals should be found in
different layers
this is plain nonsense and all you need
is just a little bit of common sense
it's a it's a lie I do believe that
there are different time periods yeah
but not different ages of billions of
years
most of these layers
shows us that the Earth is relatively a
lot younger than evolutionists believe
and most of the layers were created at
the time of the flood
it doesn't take millions of years for
things to be petrified you know the
things that you find in those layers and
you say oh this has been petrified it
must have been billions of years old no
it doesn't take billions of years for
something to be petrified they found
petrified trees standing up in these
layers through different layers which
does not make sense because trees aren't
billions of years old
but here they are telling the kids the
layers are different ages and yet all
over the world petrified trees are found
like this one standing up
connecting different Rock layers
now if you have a petrified tree
standing up running through multiple
Rock layers I don't think it's common
sense to say the layers are different
ages
not by much anyway I mean how long can a
dead tree stand there before it falls
down
five years 10 years 20 years five
thousand years I doubt that
and yet petrified trees in the poly
they're called poly strata fossils going
through multiple layers they're very
common hundreds and hundreds have been
found
it would only take one to prove the
point
but hundreds have been found petrified
standing up in Central Alabama There's a
large Coal Mine where they found all
kinds of petrified trees standing up
now the kids have been taught for years
that those two layers of coal called the
Mary Lee and the Blue Creek formation
are different ages by millions of years
and yet when you get all the fossils
together
they label them sample A B C D E F G H
you can put it together and figure out
and prove positively the Mary Lee and
the Blue Creek had to form within a few
weeks or months of each other
again it doesn't take that long for
things to get petrified they found a
petrified cowboy boot with the man's leg
bone still in it in a dry creek bed in
West Texas in 1980. now let's go back to
the trees why is there not one tree
that's older than let's say 5 000 years
because there was a flood 4 500 years
ago
the world's oldest tree is a Bristlecone
pine tree According to some test books
it's 4 300 years old
the proof of creation
of that of a flood and evolution it's
everywhere if you just open your eyes
and just ask questions if you're just
open
let's take the ocean for example when it
rains around 30 percent of the rainwater
moves into the ocean and with it the
mineral salt
today it is around three to four percent
salt and that's what they say
now
if the world was more than billions of
years old why is the sea not a lot more
saltier
that's because 4 500 years ago there was
a flood
even if the world was just one million
years old and there was water in the sea
and rivers then
the ocean should have been a lot saltier
but it's not because there was a flood
did you know that you can discover a lot
of things when you look at a reef I love
snorkeling I love it I just love to go
down in the water and just
no humans no traffic no noise just sea
life
it's a lot
that you can notice when you look at a
reef did you know that they watched the
Great Barrier Reef for 20 years they
watched it grow and calculated from the
results that the reef is less than 4 200
years old did you get that why is the
oldest Reef that we have in the whole
world only around 4 200 years old
why is there not reefs out there that's
older
maybe a
50 000 years old or a hundred thousand
years old or older
because there was a flood four thousand
five hundred years ago
the evidence is everywhere if you just
look if you look at Canyons as well if
you like look at coal beds if you look
at caves I love caves I've been to
amazing caves here in South Africa with
beautiful cave formations
and when you go inside you see this cave
formation stalactites and you know
evolutionists say that small drops of
water
created stalactites over millions of
years well they are beautiful and they
grow down from the cave ceiling
but they're not millions of years old
how do they know that it's crazy it's
it's nonsense whenever you ask them
something about something of almost
anything their answer is always millions
of years time is their excuse for
everything they found some under the
Lincoln Memorial that was only built in
1922. they found some in a mine in
Australia after they reopened the mine
when it was closed for only 55 years
there are many other examples and it
proves that it doesn't take millions and
millions of years for these things to
grow
and you know the geological column is
also made up it is nonsense
almost all of it the layers was created
at the time of the flood according to
geologist Dr John Woodmore 80 to 85
percent of the earth's land surface does
not have even three geological periods
appearing in correct consecutive order
it becomes an overall exercise of
gargantuan special pleading and
Imagination for The evolutionary
uniformitarian Paradigm to maintain that
there ever were geological periods
but still this is what they teach people
today and no one questions it or there
are a lot of people who questions it but
a lot of people who don't they just
blindly follow them and say yes okay yes
this is this is what we have to learn
this is true okay no you have to
question it
because if you don't it will mislead you
and Lead You Away from believing the
Bible which is the truth the only
absolute truth we have in this world
this happened to Charles Darwin himself
how he was misled
you know I can I can go on and give you
a lot of evidence more but I want to
tell you this story about Charles Darwin
that will shock you he didn't just
randomly start this theory of evolution
in his head this lie came from somewhere
I'm going to tell you soon but
personally I believe ultimately it came
from the Devil
to mislead people to
doubt that there is a God
that they will be judged when they die
that there is a Hell in a heaven
when Charles was 22 years old and he
actually graduated from Bible College
yes that's correct he was going to
become a preacher
but then he set sail on the ship called
HMS Beagle in 1831 to sail around the
globe to see the world but also to
collect samples of bugs for a biologist
so he went on this ship and every guy
who would become a preacher would take
his Bible with him so he probably went
with his Bible on this trip but with his
Bible he took another book that just
came out this book is called principles
of geology by Charles Lyle
this book changed everything
and Darwin said disbelief in the Bible
crept over me on a very slow right but
at last complete the right was so slow
that I felt no distress he wrote this to
a friend called Russell Wallace now I
want you to understand something
I believe that he was never a Christian
in the first place
because if you have an encounter with
something big like a lion and you go
home and you say hey I just had a
encounter with a with a lion
people look at you and say well why are
you not dead so they will think yeah you
probably lied if you have an encounter
with the Living God
where he makes you a new creation where
you accept him as Lord and Savior and he
gives you his spirit because God is
spirit and you can only worship Him in
spirit and in truth that's only how you
can connect with him
people who are not spiritual alive they
can't they can't even understand it
and so I believe that Darwin was not a
true Christian because he turned his
back on God you can't do that if you
really had an encounter with God
1 John 2 verse 19 says they went out
from us but they were not of us for if
they had been of us they would have
continued with us but they went out that
it might be complain that they all are
not of us
so I don't believe that Darwin was a
real Christian because if he was he
would have had new spiritual life God
would have made him a new creation given
him his spirit
regeneration that means you cannot be
the same as you used to be because
you're spiritually reborn a whole
different person so Darwin who now said
he's not a Christian anymore must have
not been a reborn Christian in the first
place it was probably only something
that was part of his culture just
man-made religion for him
there are many people today who call
themselves Christians but they are not
it's just man-made religion and laws and
traditions and stuff but they have no
real relationship with God John 4 24
says God is spirit and those who worship
Him must Worship in spirit and truth if
you have not been reborn spiritually
again
then you cannot it's impossible to
understand the things of God because he
is Spirit
so if you just focus on religion just
these outward traditions and things and
laws that you do it means absolutely
nothing if you are not changed on the
inside
even though you do these things you go
to church you grew up in a Christian
home it doesn't matter at all
the things of God will not make sense to
you
the Bible says the natural person does
not accept the things of the spirit of
God for they are Folly to him and he is
not able to understand them because they
are spiritually discerned if you don't
know God I want to plead with you
as your friend who really cares about
you to ask God
ask him to reveal himself to you and his
truth to you because you've been
brainwashed by the devil through other
dead religions or maybe you're an
atheist for atheists and those who
believe in evolution that's their
religion that is what their belief that
is your belief I'm not realizing that
all of it all these other religions like
I also discussed in the previous video
ultimately comes from Satan pretending
to be the God of this world just
misleading people he is the father of
all lies he works behind the scenes with
his demons through evil people and dead
religion to mislead you
2 Corinthians 4 3 says and even if our
gospel is veiled it is veiled to those
who are perishing in their case the God
of this world lower capital G
has blinded the minds of the unbelievers
to keep them from seeing the light of
the Gospel of the glory of Christ who is
the image of God for what we Proclaim is
not ourselves but Jesus Christ as Lord
with ourselves as your servants for
Jesus sake for God who said let light
shine out of Darkness has shown in our
hearts to give the light of the
knowledge of the glory of God in the
face of Jesus Christ
you see understanding the truth is
extremely important because you're very
Soul depends on it there was a flood God
created the world and he created you you
are not here by mistake and you are not
a mistake demons are real angels are
real God is real and so is Heaven and
Hell
the evidence is staring you in the face
the only problem is is you probably
never looked at it or really searched
for it because you're too busy with the
things and focus on the things of this
temporary world that is passing away but
you can die today over 300 000 people
die every day
one of these days it might be you every
second on that clock
is a second closer to your death and
where will you go
you see there needs to be a desire
within you in your inner man a real
burning desire to know the truth
and then to find it to find God himself
and he wants you to find him God says in
the Bible you will seek me and find me
when you seek me with all your heart
God has always been there just waiting
for you to truly seek him
the Bible also says The God Who made the
world and everything in it being Lord of
Heaven and Earth does not live in
temples made by man nor is he served by
human hands as though he needed anything
since he himself gives to all mankind
life and breath and everything and he
made from one man every nation of
mankind to live an old face of the Earth
having determined allotted periods and
the boundaries of their dwelling place
that they should seek God and perhaps
feel their way toward him and find him
yet he is actually not far from each one
of us for in him we live and move and
have our being
I want to ask you to really find God
you know a lot of people say when
Christians say when they share the truth
they say don't put this down my throat I
don't want to hear any of this but let
me ask you this
have you ever thought of it this way if
they truly love you they would tell you
because if you don't accept God if you
still want to live sinful you want to
kill steal murder and rape and do all
that stuff and then if you die you're
going to go into Eternal punishment
and we're warning you about this truth
you only have this short temporary
Earth this time here on this Earth to
make a decision to choose the light or
to choose the darkness and we are
warning you about the darkness
That You Don't See
it's like I'm gonna go outside and I'm
just gonna go to the car and I see that
there's a snake a very poisonous snake
and I just come back in and I sit down
and and you say all right I um
I think I've overstayed my visit I'm
gonna go home and gonna go to my car now
and I don't say anything about the snake
that is there waiting to kill you
would I be really caring about you just
sitting there and say
um all right but if you do go
um yeah I hope I see you again just
trying to be kind and nice to you no I'm
gonna tell you hey there's a snake there
that might kill you
that's what real friends do
I care about you and I want you to know
the truth
before it is too late
in the next video I'm going to show you
what the world looked like before the
flood it's going to be a very
interesting video and after that we're
going to talk about the false theory of
evolution as well in the meantime please
watch these videos here that will help
you to find God
before you go always remember
that I love you
and God loves you too
life is short so don't waste yours
see you in the next video cheers guys